composter directement sur son comptoir
de cuisine c'est ce que propose terreau
une jeune entreprise créée par elizabeth
coulombe et valérie la liberté terro a
lancé une campagne de sociaux
financement sur kickstarter qui connaît
un incroyable succès l'objectif était de
70 mille dollars on est rendu à un
million quatre cent trente cinq mille
les cofondatrices de terreau il isabelle
coulombe et valérie les libertés sont à
québec
mesdames bonsoir c'est quand même
incroyable comment vous expliquer
l'engouement des derniers jours pour
votre produit
le concert produits qui répondent à un
réel besoin
i la bête et moi ça fait longtemps qu'on
travaille sur ce projet là qu'on en
parle mais aussi on est allé rencontrer
des gens avant de concevoir ce produit
le donc on a écouté les gens qui
écoutent on se rend compte qu'on a
vraiment bien fait d écouter parce qu on
leur répondait à un réel besoin
mesdames que l'on vous avez fait quelque
chose de bien là pour que votre sociaux
financement kickstarter fonctionnent à
ce point vous avez fait quoi
en fait on pour s'assurer d'avoir un
succès avec notre campagne ce
sous-financement on analyser toutes les
dernières campagnes qui sont faits dans
les dernières années qui ont levé plus
d'un million de dollars donc on aime
travailler
plusieurs mois pour préparer cette
campagne l'heure on avait déjà plusieurs
personnes qui nous suivait déjà qu'ils
connaissent et perrot puis qu'ils
étaient prêts à acheter appareils
donc je pense que c'est un bon travail
de marketing qui a été fait au préalable
pour pour que les gens sont prêts et là
c'est donc prototype pour l'instant que
vous avez élaboré dans le cadre d'un
projet de fin d'études en design de
produit n'est ce pas expliquez-nous un
peu et enfin dans nos études en
dézinguer produit la dernière année star
à un procédé de fer puis ont pendant un
an
on doit répondre à une problématique
valérie voir des décidé de travailler
sur la gestion des déchets organiques
donc gestion des déchets du matin puis
on a rencontré différents intervenants
dans la gestion des déchets pour bien
comprendre la problématique
on a également rencontré les citoyens
pour voir comment qu'il était riche et
un tarif interagissaient avec les
matières organiques à la maison puis on
arrête donc services comme qui avait
plusieurs problèmes avec les gens
voulaient pas faire de compost qui était
pas intéressé dans le compost en raison
des odeurs des mauvais c'est pour ça
qu'on écrit un appareil qui permettait
de faire tout simplement sans avoir tous
les inconvénients du compostage et donc
madame la liberté ce que vous faites
c'est que vous mettez le compost dans la
machine et ça sort c'est broyer ça sort
un petit poudre ouais on accumule l'aude
et c'est à vous faire mesure qu'on
cuisine on fait de la semaine dans
l'appareil quand c'est plein belle île
c'est super c'est qu'on a juste a lancé
le cycle en appuyant sur des barres et
et puis le processus se fait tout seul
donc le pauvre n'y a aucune gestion à
faire on n'a pas besoin d'aller brasser
tout va être fait automatiquement la
machine s'arrête automatiquement aussi
et on part d'un volume de convier à
combien est un volume de 4.5 il est
environ 4.5 litres c'est à dire que si
je mets je sais pas des pommes toutes
sortes de choses s'est réduit jusqu'à
une petite portion de combien ça réduit
de 90% ce qui est beaucoup moins et donc
est ce que la machine est génératrice me
prend beaucoup d'énergie
non vraiment pas d'enfant de nous si ça
fait partie de nos valeurs début là que
ce soit éco énergétiques et puis c'est
comparable à une cafetière le pour un
usage de d'un terreau une fois par
semaine
ce équivalent à usage d'une cafetière
une fois par jour là donc avec une
usagère moyens
madame clos mais est ce que ça existe
ailleurs ça où je vis il va hanter tout
cela il ya d'autres produits conclure en
fait nous qu'on ait découvert un peu un
produit concurrent ses qui est en corée
par exemple ils doivent payer pour le
pas de leurs déchets dont qui ont créé
un appareil qui permettait de réduire le
poids de leurs déchets en séchant en
décevra pas les amateurs
nick donc nous qu'on ait découvert cet
appareil c'était escale nous on pourrait
l'utiliser comme une manière alternative
offert au compostage est ce que le
résultat qu'on obtient pour être
utilisée par exemple pour nourrir les
plantes comme un fertilisant
puis c'est en rencontrant différence
agronomes des professeurs à liberty
laval qu'on s'est rendu compte que oui
effectivement cette matière là est riche
en nutriments que nos seules ont besoin
dans la zone de phosphore potassium puis
ça nous aussi convaincu à poursuivre
dans cette avenue là puisque c'était
comme valérie d un petit peu cela fait
partie de nos valeurs d'entreprise des
valeurs environnementales responsables
ne pas créer des chaises supplémentaires
avec nos appareils et vous trouviez que
des ingénieurs aussi oui on a une équipe
aux criques et puis chez creaform
engineering qui nous a aidé à développer
tout le mécanisme à l'intérieur pour
s'assurer que ce soit le produit qui est
commercialisable qui est durable qui est
performante puisqu'elle des qualités
d'homme la liberté c'est quoi le coût de
production
le coût de production qu'est ce que vous
lisez belle coûts de production de
machines vous le vendez combien nous
enlevant est en ce moment y est un est
en prévente à 350 à 400 dollars et à 450
dollars sur la campagne de ce sous
financement
les premières minutes étaient vraiment
et en rab et puis sur le marché vont
être détaillées à 450 dollars
est-ce que vous donnez votre coût de
production un nom peut pas confirmer en
ce moment parce que d'enfants non on est
commandée en un prototype fonctionnel
il nous reste encore des tas d'études
étape de raffinement donc on peut pas le
confirmer parce que nous on va pouvoir
aller négocier avec toutes ses
précommandes là à les négocier à les
rencontrer nos fabrica qu'on a déjà avec
qui on est déjà en contact pour pouvoir
définir le coût final et c'est en 2020
que les produits seront disponibles
oui exact bienfaits l'écoutent traite de
production de cet appareil la baisse et
les coûts d'outillage pour pouvoir faire
les pièces de plastique par exemple les
pièces de métal ce cd coup de bol en
fait que de plus d'une centaine de
milliers de dollars
et là vous allez faire quoi vous vouliez
70000 vous apprendrez un million quatre
vous fait quoi avec cet argent là est en
fait cet argent là vraiment servira à
produire tous les appareils qui sont
fait qu'ils sont
qui sont commandés puis sinon toutes les
autres activités de l'entreprise donc
qu'on pense au département de marketing
par exemple de cette création de
nouveaux produits
puis en fait c'est que ça nous rend plus
autonome avec 78 $ ça nous aurait permis
de nous avancer un certain niveau
puis possiblement à chercher d'autres
subventions d'autres aides
gouvernementales peut être dupe
l'investissement privé alors que
présentement belle se rend complètement
autonome dans les activités de
l'entreprise et vous ça vous ça vous
donne des ailes madame la liberté pour
aller un peu plus loin encore dans ne
rien manger énormément écoute ça nous
donne beaucoup de ressources mais ça
nous donne beaucoup de travail aussi
mais ça nous permet d'aller chercher des
employés aussi de créer de nouveaux
emplois pour pouvoir nous aider à suivre
cette grosse demande le mais oui
énormément comme il habite le der garde
et où c est autonome
c'est une belle histoire félicitations
bonne chance pour la suite elisabeth
coulombe valérie l'alberta québec merci
merci beaucoup